hello everyone and welcome back to the
most awaited game of this tournament it
is of course former world champion
vishwanathan anand vs former world
champion gary kasparov and before we
check out the game there's a very nice
photo that douglas griffin posted on
twitter that happened
30 years ago uh this is the the photo
there you have it
anand versus kasparov us also honored
with the white peace against kasparov it
was the 12th round
of the tilburg tournament in the 1st of
november 1991
and this was their encounter in in round
12 anand defeated kasparov
uh but even with that loss cause paro
was able to to win um
uh first place in the event so really
really an awesome one
and it's uh nice to see that uh 30 years
from this photo
here in 2021 the two of them still face
off um over the board and
in none other than the night of sicilian
so without further ado let's check it
out
as anand opens with e4 and uh
if you're wondering how are how their
encounters went uh
up until this point well kasparov
actually has a pretty big lead in the
classical
uh time format kasparov actually has 17
wins to
wishes for uh with 31 draw and
in rapid kasparov also beat anand with a
score of
nine to four uh with 15 draws so now uh
it's not it's not much but uh vishy
definitely has a chance to
to lower the lead as he does have the
the white pieces here
and let's see what happens so e4 we
already said it's going to be a nice
sicilian defense so c5
and we're going to be following the game
that kasparov already played in round
one against uh fun war ice
and it's going to be a really really
awesome one so knight to f3
we have d6 and now d4 striking in the
center captures captures knight to f6
knight to c3 and again kasparov goes for
his knight of sicilian we have bishop to
g5
and e6 now uh we have f4 sim the same as
uh
in round one uh queen to c7 and now
bishop captures an f6 we we said that
queen to f3 is also
very much played by bishop captures and
f6 seems to be the preferred version for
for the blitz uh g captures on f6 and
only now queen to f3 we have b5 by
kasparov preparing to function to the
light square bishop
and now a3 opting for the for the same
choice that uh fun warriors did
and now knight to c6 and here if you
remember around one night captures on c6
was played
but here on and just castle's queen side
so kasparov trades off a pair of knights
on d4 we have knight captures and e4
rook captures and now queen to c5
activating the queen to a
much more active square with tempo
attacking the rook here and then
later on you're probably going to play
something like rook the b8 you're going
to try and push b4
and try and attack the white king so
anand doesn't go for queen to d1 which
is a known move here that simply defends
the rook
anand brings the rook back to d3 and it
is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
gary
continues this game uh rook to b8 if uh
if anand allows b4 then it's going to be
a very nice game for black so of course
annan plays b
for himself and the now queen back to a7
now you want to play 8th
a5 bust open the position here and then
try to create some sort of an attack
against the white king
and the kasparov is already very much
down on the clock anan spent
basically no time here he still has five
minutes on the clock whereas kasparov is
down to three minutes on the clock and
anand plays
f5 and here i think um kasparov already
had some bad feelings because this is uh
much like much like in game one things
didn't go really well for him
and now he doesn't bother with the h5
move like he did in round one which is a
very useful move in in such lines but he
goes straight for the attack he plays a5
and now anand again not rushing with
anything there's no reason to
to push for the immediate attack goes
knight to a2 which is very nice
because now if kasparov tries to open up
the position here you're just going to
recapture with the knight and
the queen and rook both now help out
with the defense of the third rank so
you're not
breaking through here anytime soon so
instead kasparov has to continue
development that they're still the
bishop the bishop and
well they're still not not fully
operational
so bishop to e7 and now bishop to e2
ana now prepares to bring this rook to
d1 we have
h5 now by kasparov and the king to b1 so
getting the king away from the
from the c file and now bishop to d7 so
the bishop says
bishops have been developed and now uh
it's uh gary to continue his attack on
the queen side
anand just puts another rook on the d
file rook h the d1 now with a lot of
pressure on the
on the d file and here as anand did not
play h4 because power grabs more space
on the king side with
h4 and now ananda also could go for some
ideas like
one fun foreign did in game one with
some like queen g4 queen to g7
but here he just captures an a5 and it's
a it's a very
interesting move because not something
you usually want to do just allow your
opponent to bust open your position in
front of the king but here it really
works out very nicely for him
so queen captures an a5 by gary and now
knight to b4
and with this capture you've basically
eliminated all of black's counterplay
here
uh because you're never capturing here
you can't push the beep on and the
bishops
don't really have um a lot of option
here to to you know
bust open the position uh and the black
was not able to play d5 in this game and
you know what we say about
when you play the sicilian and if you
manage to get the d5 moving
so here caspar transfers the game to the
c file we have rooked the c8 and
now queen to g4 now she wants to go
queen to g7
so king to f8 preventing this and now f
captures on e6 we have bishop captures
on e6
now attacking the queen and the queen
back to f3
uh and here caspar played just rook to
c5 and
now the problem for kasparov is that
anand has some three minutes on the
clock whereas gary has only about 15
seconds on the clock
uh and here uh anand played queen the e3
probably playing against kasparov's
clock if he
uh were to invest a bit more time he
would probably go for a cl
you know uh really flashy rook captures
on d6 because it really offers quite a
lot of
a lot of play but then again you will
give black some counter play the problem
is
for example if the bishop is uh uh well
if you play bishop captures rook then
you're gonna play queen captures on f6
now attacking the rook and also the
bishop is still hanging
and now you don't really have a good
move if you move the rook you're just
going to play rook captures on d6 and
now this is being threatened and
it's just a very ugly position for black
to play but black could ignore this and
play some like queen captures on a3 and
there are
a lot of complications in this position
so even if you capture the rook here for
example queen captures king k7
it's still a very maybe ugly position
for white to face in uh
in a blitz game but okay after rook the
c5 probably anand was playing on
kasparov's clock he played queen to e3
and
now kasparov plays f5 he has to he has
to activate his pieces he plays f5 he
wants to bring the bishop to f6 to grab
hold of this diagonal
and now again anand uh playing gun
gary's time
doesn't go for this rook captures on d6
again it's a really
an interesting move because after this
is played it's just uh
just a much much superior position for
for white uh but uh he goes for the khan
bishop to f3
and now caspar has to play he's very
long on the clock
and now he has to play bishop to f6 he
has to grab hold of this diagonal and
then the game just continues if he
finance captures here then bishop
captures
his bishops are now more than fully
operational but
here uh kasparov actually played f
captures on e4 and now an unplayed
bishop captures on e4
uh we rook the c4 and now bishop to d5
going for an attack on the bishop and on
the rook
and what do you play here well
best for black is probably to just
ignore this and still bring the bishop
over to f6 and
this is exactly what gary does he plays
bishop to f6 and now he gives up the
rook on c4 so bishop captures we have b
captures on c4 attacking alan's rook
here and anand just played rook captures
on d6 and it was
in this position on move 30 that gary
kasparov lost on time as there was no
more time
left on his clock so it was a it's a
pretty crazy position uh casparo now
does have the active queen the two
bishops really going after anand's king
the rook can maybe be activated somehow
but it's a really really
uh tricky position and uh well he simply
didn't have time to
calculate everything and to continue
playing this and it would seem that
blitz is a bit too fast for him now uh
maybe
maybe he'd he'd have a more more fun
playing in the rapids but
i guess he he chose blitz for a reason
and here you could continue this with
king to g7 the game continues and it
might be a very active game
but you know who are we to to know such
things but then white can play rook to
a6 attack black's queen
and now black's attack is basically over
you have to move the queen now
there there's no more attack happening
here after you move the queen
uh even a g4 and it's actually white
who's attacking if h captures so the
queen will capture with
check and it's uh well it's a very
enjoyable position and i have no doubt
caspar would enjoy playing this with the
black pieces having such a wonderful
bishop player and everything
but like i said uh on rook captures on
e6 he lost some time and
for the moment not doing all that great
in tournament three losses
uh and one draw against alexander
grayshuk so now vichy lowers the lead
and who knows how many times they will
face
each other again to lower maybe the lead
even further but we'll see how it goes
a great great victory for vichy and a
great attacking game all in all
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
kevin keith
robert aratun and jim alboy and
cruzada.com for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day